OK, we're speaking to folks who presumably are
fans of the show, although sometimes they're
not via the David Pakman show Discord, which
you can find at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. Let's go next to let's go to
Irina. Irina from. From where? From where?
Irina, you're on the air.
Ceric from Zurich. Wow, that's
a that's a perfect city, you know. Yes, from Euro
O Europe. I thought you said Zurich, Switzerland.
Switzerland, yes, that's right.
Or you are in Switzerland, OK?
Yes, well, I didn't think I would have the
chance to talk to you. I'm very grateful for your
comments that you gave. Thank you. And also,
it's interesting to see the press briefing,
some of the new President Biden, and
it's so it's good to compare it. I'm not
yeah, that's I'm very it's very informative
and helpful. And often when I get angry,
you you make a good comment. So I'm very glad
to hear that. It's it's very interesting.
The arena. Would you say that the opinion of the
United States now that Trump has been removed and
Joe Biden has been put in? Is it improving? Is our
reputation within Switzerland improving at all?
I think so, I think so. OK, I mean, of course,
I follow it. You know, I also listen to
Mr. Chomsky. Noam Chomsky. Yeah. I hope that the
Biden administration will be more a more strong
maybe, you know, maybe at this point they will
really just continue to do the things which are
necessary for a humane, democratic society.
Yes, I hope so.
In theory, in theory, that the riot on the
6th of January have the repercussion that
the crazy brother of a vegetarian chain,
Tippett's. They have a brother and he
I don't know who to whom he wrote, but it's
written in our newspaper. He wrote to a
military officer to to present to our federal
the federal government. Yes. Because of the
of the coronal measure measures they took. And
yes. I mean, he was totally inspired. That was
only a few days after the riots in the US,
in Washington, D.C. And I was glad that
I mean, here it counts as crazy. But, you know,
I think I hope that the Trump will be impeached
and convicted, of course.
Yes. He has been
impeached. But now the trial. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I mean, that he will have a
really thought that it's clear he did the
crime. Right. Right. Because this will have
repercussions to Europe and I am sure of it. We
also America sent that, you know, Europe is still
very American and still no doubt about it.
Irina, thank you so much for the call. I'm
going to let you go because I have a lot of people
waiting. Always great to hear from our friends in
Switzerland, Switzerland, one of
my favorite favorite countries.
Let's speak next to radical capitalist Jack.
Radical capitalist Jack. You are on the air.
You just had one question is, do you think
anything further is going to happen to Marjorie
Kilogramme? I think she stands a chance
being removed from her position or now?
No, I don't think so. If you look in
history at when members of Congress
have actually been expelled, it's been five
two of them were actually convicted of crimes
and that's why they got expelled. The other three
were supporting the Confederacy in the Civil War.
So it's it's I don't see it as likely.
All right. Thank you.
My pleasure. OK, there we go. There is
there is Jack, radical capitalist Jack.